procès j'ai trouvé vraiment que le monde
finalement était formé de gens
merveilleux aidé de jean ignoble en fait
vous ne savez pas comment votre fils est
mort vous devez enquêter sur tout et
vous confronter ils étaient ni sur la
liste des morts ni sur les db c'est une
surveillance et hopitalisé il était
nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tout cela nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée
nouveautés cette semaine vos réactions
sur le télégramme verte et france vous
pouvez prendre part au débat donner
votre opinion et interpeller nos invités
au sommaire de ce mardi 12 octobre le
prix du gasoil qui explose en france et
atteint des niveaux records hausse de
28% en un an le prix moyen la pompe est
désormais d'un euro 54 c'est plus
qu'avant la crise des gilet jaune en
2018 un coup de massue pour beaucoup de
ménages déjà victime de l'augmentation
des prix du gaz et d'électricité le
gouvernement lui défend son bilan en
matière de pouvoir d'achat chiffres
officiels à l'appui mais est-ce
suffisant sur le pouvoir d'achat at on
vraiment tout essayé peut-on clairement
aller plus loin et encore le temps donc
de donner vos avis et réagir sur le
conte télégramme berthet france
nous irons suite au royaume uni où barry
johnson est accablé pour sa gestion du
kobe 19 grave erreur important retard
dans la gestion du début de la pandémie
c'est la conclusion d'un rapport
parlementaire publié aujourd'hui le
royaume uni particulièrement touché par
le cos vide avec presque cent
trente-huit mille morts c'est l'objet de
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
et puis au sommaire à 21h que doit-on
retenir du plan france 2030 annoncé par
emmanuel macron un plan destiné à
défendre la souveraineté économique de
notre pays à l'international hydrogène
vert ou assure électrique réacteurs
nucléaires innovant de petite taille
agriculture tourné vers la robotique et
la génétique des secteurs prioritaires
selon le chef de l'état qui débloquera
30 milliards d'euros sur cinq ans
l'opposition dénonce une démarche
électoraliste à la proche de la
présidentielle décryptage dans une heure
nouvelle envolée des prix du gasoil en
france des records atteint même près
d'un euro 54 en moyenne le litre on le
disait c'est un peu plus qu'en octobre
2018 moment où la flambée du prix à la
pompe avait déclenché le mouvement des
gilet jaune on retrouve notre reporter
estelle farges à proximité d'une station
service à paris bonsoir estelle le prix
moyen à la pompe du litre de gasoil a
donc augmenté et on imagine que cette
hausse est très bien ressenti même
douloureusement par les automobilistes
pas exactement stéphanie à le passage à
la pompe est de plus en plus douloureux
pour les automobilistes près d'un euro
54 le litre de gazole du côté du sans
plomb 95 par exemple il est passé
désormais il a dépassé désormais à la
barre des 1 euro 60 selon les données du
ministère de la transition écologique
alors forcément à la sortie de la
station le constat est amer pour les
automobilistes certains comparent les
stations afin de trouver à la moins
chère d'autres sont passés sur des
véhicules hybrides pour moi consommer
bref si chacun y va de sa petite astuce
la facture est salée trop salée même
pour certains je vous proposais d'
écouter les automobilistes qui nous
avons pu par les ventes a failli oui ça
se remarque tous les jours après on
essaye de varier selon les stations
essence attention ils sont ce qui coûte
le moins cher vous le prix les moins
chers la plupart du temps sans pour 95
on va le trouver un euro 60 1 euros 60
alors qu'avant c'était un 40 comme ça
j'ai eu
presque autant avec 30 euros vous pouvez
travailler pendant trois jours mais
maintenant c'est quasiment impossible
je travaille juste une journée des
millions c'est devenu bien plus
important qu'il ya quelques années la
quote-part du du prix de l'essence sur
les frais de véhicules pour ceux qui
roulent en voiture et déjà passer à
l'hybride et l'électrique
vraisemblablement oui mais encore qu' il
faudrait qu'il déborde un peu partout
qui sont en état et que le prix des
recharges sont un peu plus structuré
parce qu'on peut passer d'un extrême à
l'autre c'est pas vraiment le plein
plein mais c'est 50 euros mon ami on
avait vingt quinze litres donc c'est un
peu cher passé à les tricks non parce
que faute d avoir les moyens mais et
puis moi sinon je pense qu'on va manger
les pissenlits par la racine
voilà on vous l'aurez compris c'est
évidemment une une augmentation à qui
pèse sur les finances des automobilistes
et qui est d'autant plus remarquée car
l'année dernière pendant l a crise
sanitaire le litre de gazole était aux
alentours d'1 euro 16 contre 1 euros 54
donc aujourd'hui est l etat qui pourrait
intervenir pour donner un coup de pouce
exactement stéphanie sur le diesel et
l'essence si l'envolée se poursuit il
faudra réagir déclarations de bruno le
maire en début du mois d'octobre le
ministre de l'économie qui a donc laissé
à la porte ouverte à une aide du
gouvernement
mais il l'a rappelé le cap doit être
celui de la transition écologique
objectif donc pour le gouvernement
favoriser le passage à l'électrique
merci estelle farges prix record du
gasoil donc mais aussi augmentation des
prix du gaz et d'électricité une facture
donc bien salée à la fin du mois pour
les ménages français est un pouvoir
d'achat plus que jamais au centre de la
campagne présidentielle à six mois du
scrutin le gouvernement met en avant les
mesures concrètes qu'il est mis en place
mais est il allé assez loin at on
vraiment tout essayé vous pouvez
d'ailleurs toujours continué de réagir
sur notre compte télégramme verte et
france est l'objet en tout cas de notre
face à face ce soir
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir
david guiraud porte-parole jeunesse de
la france insoumise bonsoir david biraud
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés une
philippe millet sénateurs l ère des deux
sèvres par parole de valérie pécresse
soit on vient de le voir les français
dégustons matière de pouvoir d'achat si
je reprends la question centrale du
débat est évidemment une formule très
célèbre rendu célèbre par mitterrand en
81 13 sur le show m'adresse qu'on a
vraiment tout essayé pour le pouvoir
d'achat david biraud mais moi je pense
que le gouvernement prend les français
pour des abrutis en nous expliquant
alors là c'est les chiffres récents donc
le niveau de vie a augmenté donc moi
j'aimerais bien savoir honnêtement
j'aimerais bien savoir on a perdu deux
ans de croissance les plans de
licenciements ont explosé la dares nous
dit plus de mille plans de licenciements
la vie est plus chère sur de nombreux
produits je pense aux produits aux
produits frais +2 4% le gaz
l'électricité plus de 12%
toutes les autres évaluations
précédentes qui ont mesuré un peu les
effets de la politique d' emmanuel
macron sur sur les français montrent que
par exemple les 5 % les plus pauvres
hyper tandis que les plus riches eux
voient leurs revenus exploser et qu'en
fait dans cette espèce de tripatouillage
statistiques il n'y a que deux shows
sites qui sont sûr c'est que les
milliardaires et les plus riches de ce
pays se sont gavés ils ont gagné près de
175 milliards d'euros entre mars et
décembre 2020 c'est à dire en pleine
crise et que les français eux survivent
et ils survivent et la seule chose qui
leur a permis de ne pas avoir la tête
complètement sous l'eau c'est quoi ces
les mesures qui ont arraché les gilet
jaune c'est des mesures concrètes de
pouvoir d'achat mais même ça même ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on a distribués
aux français mais qu'on va le reprendre
dans l'avenir parce que par exemple sur
les mesures d'âge il est jeune c'est 3
milliards d'euros qu'on a fait envoyer
dans les comptes de la sécurité sociale
et qu'est ce qu'on est en train de nous
dire aujourd'hui ça coûte trop cher la
sécurité sociale ya un trou il va
falloir faire des coupes dans les
dépenses de la sécurité sociale donc
tout ça et est une embrouille pour les
français et moi je suis pas d'accord
avec cette manière de faire de présenter
pour le gouvernement que rien tout va
bien tout va bien alors les gens ont
faim il y en a sur un français sur cinq
qui sauta repas mais tout va bien et a
foncé sur cinq qui dit avoir du mal à à
payer sa facture énergétique mais tout
va bien ben non moi je suis pas d'accord
alors c'est vrai que cette petite
musique 1
elle revient dans dans vos commentaires
on va le voir un sandrine c
le message précédent effectivement cette
petite musique autour de lier cette
chasse à la fraude fiscale
adama papers combien de milliards déjà
11 milliards trois cent mille nous nous
dit
cet internaute augmentation du smic
n'hésitez pas à rappeler que la france
compte aujourd'hui 2 millions de pauvres
vous êtes d'accord avec cette opposition
confère en permanence les pauvres de
plus en plus pauvres les riches de plus
en plus riches et rien n'a été fait pour
les plus modestes dans ce pays alors je
ne recherche de théâtre d'une autre
façon mais de façon générale on voit
bien que l'écart s'est agrandi entre
ceux qui étaient les plus riches et ceux
qui sont les plus modestes on le
constate et on voit à travers les
chiffres notamment lorsqu on fait
l'analyse de toutes les mesures sociales
d'accompagnement ça c'est un constat en
même temps malgré la situation difficile
de la de la crise qu vide on voit bien
que l'économie aussi repart et qu'on a
des capacités d'emploi et de progression
en matière salariale voilà donc je crois
que c'est un ensemble de choses on parle
là on a eu l'exemple tout à l'heure de
pouvoir d'achat ou du coût du carburant
est à la fois un débat sur les salaires
les rémunérations le le le prix de la
ville du coût de la vie on voit en tous
les cas il ya un combat qu'on doit mener
collectivement c'est le notamment toulon
ge pour autour de la pauvreté toulon
j'ai autour des travailleurs pauvres
tout c'est un sujet qui est important
donc on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui on a
besoin de remettre à plat sa tombe de
sujets sur ce volet là et que ces
efforts qui sont doivent être
nécessaires l'écart dans tous les cas de
se réduire david guiraud vous dépeignez
un tableau très noir que beaucoup des
peines mais c'est va qui ils sont mais y
avoir un petit peu deux approches en les
chiffres de l'insee tenez qui nous
disent eh bien oui le quinquennat
maquereau a permis d'augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat même s'il semblerait
quand on regarde ça en valeur absolue
qu'il est davantage confites et aux plus
aisés aux plus modestes mais vous vous
contestez clairement ces chiffres on
rappelle quand même quelques mesures
phares pas toutes les citer ici
suppression de la taxe d'habitation pour
de nombreux français
réduction de l'impôt sur le revenu prime
d'activité pour beaucoup vous répondez
quoi c'est pas suffisant jamais deux
choses c'est que d'abord ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que les mesures qu'on a
donnée aux plus riches sous ce
quinquennat c'est pour la vie et c'est
sans condition les mesures qu'on a
donnée aux plus pauvres c'est des
mesures de quoi de distribution entre
pauvres c'est à dire qu'en fait on va
supprimer des cotisations sociales bon
vous dire vous allez gagner du pouvoir
d'achat donc on supprime des cotisations
sociales et les cotisations sociales
elles sont utiles aux gens au moment de
partir à la retraite ou à l'assurance
chômage là on est en train de casser
l'assurance chômage donc si vous êtes
chômeur par un plat vous avez un emploi
on vous supprime votre cotisation
sociale vous gagnez un petit peu de
pouvoir d'achat allait d'accord mais si
vous êtes au chômage est bas vous fait
massacrer socialement c'est cela la
réalité de ces excès il y en a qui sont
vraiment sans condition pour la vie pour
les riches et puis pour les pauvres vous
allez voir la cavitation c'est sans
condition et celle pour les
travailleurs
atypiques mans / sur ces suppressions de
taxes je rappelle que pour les plus
pauvres le seul cercle le service public
c'est aussi un salaire mais c'est à dire
que le service public la gratuité de
certains éléments le fait de les avoirs
disponibles à côté de soi ça fait partie
de la vie des gens qui sont démunis dans
ce pays et quand vous justement retirer
certaines allocations à des
collectivités locales parce que la taxe
d'habitation c'est aussi ça on n'est pas
encore totalement de sourdes comment
l'état va compenser tout ça veut dire
qu'il va vraiment
pour le 28 ans aujourd'hui c'est clair
et donc en charente encore en ces
déluges euros et de façon originale
aujourd'hui une compensation de l'état
donc on voit bien que là il ya un choix
politique que je ne partage pas
forcément sur cette exonération mais que
en matière de moyens et de sa vie sa
portée pour auprès des collectivités
pour l'instant il n'y a pas d'inquiétude
la vraie question elle avait 15 ou
qu'évoquer cecab la durée dans la durée
parce qu'on voit bien que on est sur des
actions plutôt court terme qui sont
souvent des actions qui se limite
d'ailleurs à un quinquennat on manque de
vision plus globale et que toutes les
cages à réduire jusqu'à 2003 la maison
tous les horaires ne pas le problème des
travailleurs pauvres on règle le panneau
pour le problème de ceux qui sont juste
à la marge à un moment donné pour lequel
il n'y a pas de musée d'accompagnement
suffisante voilà c'est un vrai sujet de
fond mais de nouveau je crois que
aujourd'hui c'est une vision globale
c'est les salaires c'est la capacité
aussi de maîtrise à sa tombe du coût de
la vie de tous les jours et puis ses
galons tout ce qui concerne notamment
les retraites on avait cet après midi à
un texte sur la locale sur les hauteurs
de cap et c'est un des sujets voilà donc
quoi bien c'est une vision globale et
par rapport aux problématiques des
recettes qui ne rentrent plus notamment
au niveau de la sécurité sociale c'est
tout le débat de la question je suis
désolé ils sont derrière vous me
cherchez déployés mais mais c'est vrai
que ça revient souvent c'est ses
cotisations sociales ses ces taxes qui
plombe
là encore on n'a pas tout essayé parce
qu'il ya eu quand même des efforts de
consentis sur ce thème ces cotisations
sociales qui ont été tout de même
réduites à vis de dire oui mais les
cotisations sociales fonds publics c'est
du salaire différé c'est du salaire que
vous avez après par exemple quand vous
cotisez pour votre retraite c'est vrai
que sur la feuille de paye ça vous
ferait pas plaisir mais quand vous êtes
à la retraite vous êtes content de
partir à la retraite et la réforme de
justement des retraites qui était prévu
c'était le fait de pouvoir crainte de
devoir avoir à travailler un deux trois
quatre ans de plus dans votre vie pour
pouvoir retrouver le niveau qu'on vous a
volé enfin c'est ça le truc donc quand
on dit à la défense nationale mais non
mais vous je me disais quand vous êtes
serait-ce qu'un élan show nice mais on
va changer l'arrivée
d'emile dur pour moi love cotiser pour
sa retraite son côté pas pour sa
retraite on cotise pour le régime
général des retraites donc c'est une
approche différente
la nuance est comme je vous ai cru que
m'ont donné par les deux ans de plus
avec une réforme c'est aussi pour nous
qu'on le fait mais de quatre ans l'idée
des lacs d'antiques moi je pense qu'il
ya des leviers d'action c'est pas vrai
qu'il y en a pas on a proposé une loi
d'urgence sociale à la faune sont
soumises cette porte ex mikami
respectives donc le smic à 1400 euros
net parce que ça c'est une manière
d'augmenter directement les salaires
pour les plus petites entreprises qui
auraient du mal à trouver de la
trésorerie qu'est ce qu'on fait on fait
un fond de solidarité inter entreprises
le but c'est que ça soit les plus
grandes entreprises qui n'ont pas de mal
à payer ses impôts là qu'ils payent plus
et les petites entreprises qu'elles
soient aidés par ce fonds de solidarité
pour équilibrer un peu les efforts pour
augmenter le smic ça c'est pour le smic
et maintenant on a d'autres choses à
faire on peut augmenter les salaires de
la fonction publique parce que ça ça
dépend de qui de l'état on peut bloquer
les prix des prix de première des
produits de première nécessité c'est
quelque chose qu'il est possible de
faire d'ailleurs le gouvernement vient
de le faire le seul problème aujourd'hui
fait vis-à-vis du gaz et de
l'électricité
mais une fois que la hausse a eu lieu
donc tout ça n'a aucun sens et par
ailleurs je le dis comme ça tant que ce
secteur sera de plus en plus privatisé
et qu'on a obéré obéira aux règles de
l'union européenne eh ben les salles et
les
lee on évolue en fonction de l'offre et
la demande plus d'un objet creuser ma
tombe a passé la parole fait au niveau
des mesures notamment qui sont
aujourd'hui portés par la presse comme
xavier bertrand lui un ski à kong 1 mais
ça c'est un autre débat veut augmenter
de 200 euros les travailleurs au smic 1
via la prime d'activité défiscalisation
des heures sup pour tout le monde y
compris des entreprises chez valérie
pécresse seront faits allant des
globalement avant tout sur le fait
d'avoir une augmentation de salaire pour
les bas salaires jusqu'à deux fois le
smic l'idée c'est que on puisse avoir
plus de rémunération pour les salariés
mais pas content c'est une baisse des
charges salariales d'accord donc là ça
n'impacte pas directement l'entreprise à
ses deux premiers volets deuxième volet
c'est de faire en sorte que les salariés
puissent 1 participe de plus fortement
au capital notamment des grandes
entreprises donc là on est sur la
participation keita un principe très
gaulliste important de tout ça qui
pointent point pourtant et 3 c au guide
également la capacité à moment donné de
pouvoir avoir un peu un lissage dans la
durée notamment des efforts parce que
lorsque l'on fait un mort une
exonération de masse salariale ça veut
dire que ce sont des cotisations qui
rentre au moins et donc quel grand débat
de la durée du temps de travail qui est
un point essentiel chez nous et
notamment d'avoir une capacité de
flexibilité dans les entreprises pour
pardonner ses capacités voilà donc ça
c'est un des différences fondamentales
il a dirigé la destinée
non seulement parce que la grogne qui
sont tous âges
c'est justement le poème c'est que la
manière dont vous financer par exemple
le fait de gagner en pouvoir d'achat
dans les entreprises c'est de supprimer
les cotisations sociales mais encore une
fois les cotisations sociales c'est du
salaire différé c'est du salaire que
vous retrouvez dans votre vie quand vous
êtes en galère c'est ça la cotisation
sociale c'est je m'assure je m'assure en
cas de souci pour moi et en cas de souci
pour les autres et quand j'en ai besoin
je le reçois il ya des moments où vous
allez peut-être pas recevoir tel ou tel
rythme d'enfer si vous aussi vous briser
la jambe sur votre lieu de travail si
vous couper un doigt ou etc ce sera
quand même utile d'avoir cotisé fed a
maintenu ans quand même parce que l'idée
c'est que lorsque l'état d'autres
organisent une série de modifications
sur les cotisations sociales le principe
de la loi veil qui font que y ait une
compensation pour que le sujet n'est pas
directement sur le budget de la sécurité
sociale il est réellement sur le budget
général de l'état et donc ça renvoie à
la fois la capacité da réduire d'à côté
les bourses publiques mais surtout pour
nous la capacité de produire plus pour
créer la richesse voilà donc à partir de
là on peut voir tous les grands
principes on sait qu'aujourd'hui le
principe général c'est comment on
retrouve de la richesse dans ce pays est
à la fois la croissance pour l'assassin
nombre de mesures qui dépasse le débat
d'aujourd'hui mais c'est également cette
notion de temps de travail qui m'ont
évidemment quand on parle de gens de la
croissance mais enfin c'est vrai que
c'est poussif de d'en récupérer le
bénéfice nous dit d'ailleurs le mini de
l'économie aujourd'hui porté par cette
croissance fier de l'être ça va marcher
selon vous des libéraux mais la
croissance fin bon on a fermé le pays
pendant un an et demi on a tous fermés
c'est un jeu dit on à baisser les stores
allez tout le monde rentre chez lui donc
forcément la croissance a plongé on a
perdu je sais plus combien de % de
croissance 6,7 et là on nous dit mais
c'est génial la croissance augmente de
6% là évidemment vu qu'on avait tous
fermés ça ne peut que augmenté mais cet
indicateur la n'a aucune valeur par
rapport à ce qui se passe vraiment dans
l'économie réelle
mais camille tout partout comme et non
verbale c'est un rattrapage sur le
terrain on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui au
delà même du rattrapage tard moi je suis
très proche des pme de mon territoire
aujourd'hui on est largement au dessus
j'irai de des carnets de commandes avant
crise et on voit bien que l'enjeu
aujourd'hui c'est plus sa capacité à
trouver des travailleurs dans les
entreprises donc ça renvoie d'abord le
débat de l'attractivité des métiers et
de la rémunération donc voilà donc on
sent bien qu'aujourd'hui et quand même
niveau du son et la croissance ça va
très vite et à vis pas dans les 210
c'est à dire que dès qu'on a une
capacité d'avoir un peu de croissance ça
rentre or faire entrer des ddd
cotisations voilà donc voilà honnêtement
moi je suis vraiment vous vous leurrer
si vous pensez que là aujourd'hui les
chiffres de la croissance me le dire
autre chose que juste on a rouvert les
entreprises et donc forcément le chiffre
de l'activité parce que la croissance et
ce à sa mesure l'activité à la richesse
de ma région et moi on a tous fermés on
a tous rouverts donc forcément
statistiquement ça augmente mais par
contre il ya par exemple il ya des défis
concrets qui nous attendent par exemple
l'état a fait des prêts garantis vous
souvenez que ça vient battre trichet la
dette privée est en train d'exploser et
la dette privée
bah oui mais la dette privée je peux
vous dire que ces quelques milliers en
plus et le problème de la dette privée
c'est que autant qu'en l'état à une
dette on peut on peut s'arranger et
c'est avec les organismes internationaux
avec les banques quand c'est quelqu'un
qui ferme une entreprise une fois qu'ils
ferment il peut plus payer ses finir
quand il à 0 sur le compte en banque
c'est terminé et là c'est et c'est ça
qui est le plus dangereux donc on a
demandé et ça c'est une mesure vraiment
qu'on compte demande le gouvernement
devrait l'entendre ça devrait faire
l'unanimité de reporter le remboursement
des prendre des prêts garanties d'état
qui arrivent bientôt à échéance et que
plein de gens ne pourraient pas payer et
6 pc la fermeture est là je peux vous
dire que les chiffres de la croissance
vous allez rigoler quand vous allez voir
on a vu regardez alors c'est beaucoup de
de twitter à deux pas de tout et
excusez-moi de messages sans télégramme
c'est pas tout à fait pareil et c'est
surtout pas le même support sortir de
l'euro et de l'ue c'est le rôle
problèmes sont souveraineté monétaire
pas de pouvoir ça revient souvent cette
idée que bruxelles nous coince un peu
notamment sur le pouvoir d'achat
philippe rouyer sur ce thème est ce que
vous partagez ce diagnostic de alors moi
je partage pas et en même temps en ce
moment heureusement que devant brooks
aide pour faire en sorte que les taux
d'intérêt de nos prêts reste
relativement bas donc à un moment donné
on est contents de trouver lorsqu'on a
besoin d'outils d'harmonisation ou deux
pour 21 des trois niveaux concernant les
taux d'intérêt voilà donc pour moi le
langer pas la même si la réglementation
européenne elle pose des questions vous
avez évoqué par l'exemple d'électricité
c'est bon exemple nous font croire que
le régime européen on vous reconnaît
soit on est une production d'électricité
plus découvrez les sopal même c'est
complètement faux les règles
s'appliquent à tout le monde donc c'est
pas le statut des entreprises donc c'est
pour cette fois dans le discernement du
monopole d'edf semblait simple
d'application sellem dès lors que la
commissaire et son électricité s'engage
autour de ça elle est la capite de le
faire donc chaud qu'aujourd'hui il faut
avoir en tête que c'est parfois
contraignant et notamment en matière de
normes à ya plein de sous on fait la
liste sans déficit et qu'on se mettre en
avant et en même temps lorsqu'on est sur
des enjeux économiques et notamment des
hors-jeu pour maintenir la situation
générale on peut avoir besoin de cet
outil généraliser
ce qui se passe c'est que l'union
européenne libéralise des prix par an ce
qui vous arrive sur le gaz et l'énergie
c'est aussi une conséquence directe du
fait qu'on libéralise le système de
vente de production énergétique
c'est-à-dire qu'on donne au privé la
capacité de gérer les prix et le privé
ils feraient quoi il fait des bénéfices
et puis regarde un truc tout simple
l'offre et la demande ils sont fous le
privé de savoir si utiles socialement et
je n'en veux pas je n'en veux pas aux
prix mais je veux dire c'est dans sa
nature de ne pas en avoir grand chose à
faire de l'utilité sociale d'une chose
mais de dire il ya l'offre et la demande
et quand vous réfléchissez comme ça et
c'est le modèle que porte l'union
européenne c'est la libéralisation de ce
secteur là c'est le projet recul par
exemple très récemment projet recul ti
vise à découper edf en deux parties dont
la partie la plus rentable elle va au
privé toujours le l'état se ramasse la
partie amont rentable au passage mais le
l'aboutissement de tout ça mais vous
l'avez vous avez des exemples concrets
au texas ils ont fait ça alors c'est
l'offre et la demande donc au texas
qu'est ce qui s'est passé récemment il
ya eu la vague de froid vous l'avez vu
donc les consommations explosé et les
jambes a vu que la consommation exploser
les prix ont explosé et il se retrouvait
avec des milliers d'euros de factures
pour quelques heures à peine 2
d'utilisation de l'électricité c'est ça
la libéralisation certaines réfléchit
pas les assistés sociaux nationale est
essentiel donc aux nationalistes tout ça
si on évoque les son électricité c'est
tout le débat porte du nucléaire
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'on se rend
compte qu'aujourd'hui le nucléaire est
nécessaire parce que emmène au delà des
enjeux de carter décarbonée c'est un
sens c'est aussi clairement le débat sur
les tarifs et la métrite ait donc voilà
donc à partir de là il ya des soit
traitée gic le problème c'est tout le
débat de l'anticipation parce que là
c'est comme un paquebot à ce que prônait
décision il faut déjà d avoir le retour
est donc ça fait partie en tout cas des
sujets sur la table mais le nucléaire le
nucléaire mais ça coûte plus cher que
d'investir dans les énergies
renouvelables le nucléaire c'est une
énergie qui est finie on n'a pas les
yeux que le parquet n'avait pas les plus
aimés
fléchir votre
cycle est alors légèrement non non non
je ne suis pas satisfait du système
actuel je ne pense pas qu'il faille y
retourner au charbon il peut faire les
choses de manière ordonnée et propre il
n'y a pas de problème mais il faut pas
qu'il oublie tout ça d'ici le 2500
d'hermès mais que c'est le problème
attendez une aide accrue suite non non
on est ronde attendant cette rapidité et
je vais finir seulement un impact sur le
pouvoir d'achat rapidité ces hausses en
% de renouvelables d'ici 2050 nous
laisse un peu de temps pardon hein
maintenant je vous dis le renouvela sur
le nucléaire le parc nucléaire il est
fini il ya que deux choix y'en a pas 36
ans ou bien on le continu c'est-à-dire
qu'on fait le grand carénage notamment
pour rénover des centrales qui sont à
bout de souffle pour essayer de les
permettre de respirer donc on leur met
le pacemaker comme ça c'est c'est ça on
met un pacemaker adea des industries
nucléaires ça coûte cent milliards
d'euros selon la cour des comptes 150
milliards seront selon d'autres c'est
extrêmement cher l'argent qu'on investit
dans le nucléaire en faisant ça 1 euro
vous l'utilisez qu'une fois donc c'est
de l'argent qu'on investira pas dans la
transition écologique bien mais je dis
ça parce que tu ailles alors on va pas
entamer le débat musclé mais 30 mai
ça sera l'objet dans notre
pouvoir d'achat 6 0 pour revenir à la
question de fond pouvoir d'achat ce
système est donc un moment donné on est
vraiment de revenir sur ce sujet sur
lequel on attend très rapidement c'est
très drôle comme leicester 2e panaf les
small nucléaire reactor c'est quelque
chose dont on nous dit que ça pourra pas
être vendu avant 2030 et donc on pourra
pas faire de production en masse avant
2040 il paraît qu'à une urgence
écologique moi je suis désolé si on
parle de quelque chose qui n'est pas
prêt avant 2040 déjà c'est pas sérieux
alors plus audacieuses et des artistes
ou des bottes 70
avec
la gestion des pandémies coronavirus
épinglé au royaume uni un rapport
parlementaire publié aujourd'hui parlent
de grave erreur et de retards trop
importants dans les politiques mises en
place par le gouvernement de boris
johnson de mauvaises décisions des
scientifiques également qu'ils ont fait
du royaume uni l'un des pays les plus
touchés d'europe par le cos vide les
détails avec chadia edwars dachy
correspondante verte et internationale
cet atelier un traumatisme à des
émotions très fortes ma meilleure amie
par exemple qui a perdu sa mère lors de
l'épidémie de covin est furieuse contre
le gouvernement et sa gestion de la
pandémie elle n'est pas la seule pour
des milliers de familles en deuil dans
tout le pays ce rapport est une lecture
très difficile
il s'intitule coronavirus les leçons
tirées à ce jour et il établit qu'en
repoussant la mise en place du
confinement du 23 mars 2020 le bureau du
premier ministre a commis l'une des plus
graves erreurs de politique publique de
l'histoire du royaume uni pire encore la
gestion de la pandémie par le
gouvernement a mené à vingt mille décès
évitables un ministre du bureau du
cabinet n'a ni réfuter ni même essayé de
présenter des excuses face à ces
conclusions
cela ne donne pas une bonne image de
stephen barclay ministre du bureau du
cabinet qui lors de ce même entretien a
refusé à onze reprises de présenter des
excuses le rapport en lui-même est très
dense ce sont 150 pages qui ont pris
quasiment un an jour pour jour depuis le
véritable début de l'investigation
l'étude a couvert de nombreux domaines
clés dont la préparation aux épidémies
les mesures de distanciation assistance
sociale et l'impact sur certaines
communautés aussi bien sûr que sur la
vaccination
c'est un véritable déferlement de
critiques avec certes un point majeur de
préoccupations telles que l'accès aux
équipements de protection individuelle
les failles du système track and trace
du gouvernement le fait que boris
johnson avait déclaré au début de
l'épidémie que les maisons de soins ne
seraient pas touchés nous savons a
posteriori qu'elles ont été parmi les
plus touchées il ya également de
nombreuses critiques sur la question des
mouvements à savoir si boris johnson
n'aurait pas dû fermer les frontières
beaucoup plus tôt
mais les résultats clés remonte à il ya
environ vingt mois au 23 mars lorsque le
royaume uni a entamé son premier
confinement il est affirmé dans ce
rapport que certains scientifiques
parlait déjà deux mois plus tôt de
problème de préparation face à une
pandémie à cette échelle et que boris
johnson a été bien trop long à réagir
le premier ministre et son gouvernement
n'ont eu de cesse de répéter que la
politique était guidé par les chiffres
et la science et ont toujours maintenu
qu'il prenait des mesures en fonction
des faits qui leur étaient présentées et
qu'ils n'abandonnent pas leur promesse
de permettre une enquête sur la pandémie
et sa gestion par le gouvernement mais
il faudrait attendre au moins jusqu'au
printemps
tout cela pour dire que ce rapport ne
vise pas à désigner des coupables
il s'agit d'une citation directe mais
certains disent d'ores et déjà qu'il
n'ya qu'un coupable et que c'est bien le
gouvernement de points
d'affilée
et pour en parler nous sommes avec paul
thompson président du parti conservateur
britannique en france bonsoir paul
thompson merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france un confinement
tardive de grosses erreurs fatalisme
face à la propagation du cog vide c'est
ce qui a conduit à l'un des plus
importants et chef de de santé publique
1 ce sont les mots très durs du rapport
parlementaire publié aujourd'hui au
royaume uni vous partager ce constat par
thomson
je pense que
le reportage que vous en avez fait
donne une tonalité
un peu plus
agressive que ce que que ce qui figure
vraiment rendre un rapport d'après des
commentaires que j'ai lu de réponse j'ai
pas lu le rapport du même nom presse de
préciser c'est à dire que il y a eu et
ce n'est pas une nouveauté des erreurs
majeures commises au royaume uni tout le
monde au courant je pense que si vous
avez boris johnson en face de vous il là
vous aurez lui-même son tourner autour
du pot
et je rappelle que ça a été le cas dans
d'autres payer aux états unis en france
la gravité de la chose a été
sous-estimée dans un premier temps un
peu partout au royaume uni
le rapport indique
à peu près 15 jours ont été perdus et
une coût en termes de vies humaines
pour des couleurs ces quinze jours de
perdus étaient très lourds très lourds
se chiffrant par des milliers de morts
dont bien sûr quand des personnes
touchées c'est forcément quelque chose
de traumatisant et pour deux pour les
autorités
[Musique]
cette
quelque chose qui est dur à porter dans
une certaine mesure mais il faut quand
même rappeler que ce n'était pas quelque
chose qui était qui était prévu donc il
s'agit quand même de deux mètres tout
cela dans le contexte très particulier
de ce pain de mie pas comme ça ce qui
est clairement reproché aussi à boris
johnson c'est que d'une certaine manière
il a tardé à imposer un un confinement
strict avait pourtant des signes avant
coureurs notamment un modèle de nîmes
perrier college london qui affirmaient
qu'une épidémie nos jeunes ont dit gay
pouvait entraîner cinq cent mille morts
montrant qu un confinement était
inévitable il n'en a pas pris content il
n'en a pas tenu compte au départ d'une
certaine manière il a fait le choix de
l'économie c'est ce qu'on lui reproche
peut-être aujourd'hui
il y là il suivit et il faut d'abord
préciser et c'est une indication
importante pour les débats dans tous les
pays que les scientifiques ne sont en
tous du même avis je parle de
scientifiques
bien établie sérieux crédible
en allemagne il ya eu des divergences
importantes concernant détendue du
confinement par exemple en france aussi
et en angleterre dans un premier temps
les scientifiques y étaient les plus
écoutées dans un premier temps par la
part de l'autorité est activement
prônait une politique
attentiste en disant même il vaut mieux
laisser des choses
courir
pour que le pic de la pandémie ait lieu
plus tôt en était que quand l'hiver
rétrospectivement on voit que c'était
une une erreur qui a eu des conséquences
très lourdes
bordeaux et son gouvernement dans un
premier temps on écoutait
cccc conseil important ce n'est pas lui
même un épidémiologiste
donc qu'ils s'appuient sur des experts
n'a rien de choquant je mens et le
gouvernement essaie quand même
réalisé relativement rapide ont ils ont
perdu selon le rapport quinze jours
précieux donc
donc je dis
c'est un peu similaire une situation en
france pensent je ne cherche pas change
de sujet mais il y en a en france il y
avait eu des erreurs c'est assez
monumentale de commises ont toutes
atteint au début on n'a pas besoin de
masquer ce même contrée indiqué
attendait c'était archi faux bond des
autorités ont été pris de court
ils ont pendant un certain temps tu as
touché dans un choc comme on dit et et
après ils se sont mis sérieusement au
travail pour essayer de rectifier le
jazz qui a été faire vos amis mais aussi
avec le programme de vaccination qui
était quand même un succès
extraordinaire et qui a été
qui a été
impulsée par le gouvernement y compris
barcelone c'est parce qu'il ya eu une
copie coopération privé université
gouvernement a tout à fait un dock suis
generis unique qui a donné de très bons
résultats très très rapidement et
d'ailleurs qui a permis de mettre sur le
marché des produits à prix coûtant et il
avait alors amené à distribuer dans
d'autres pays ces produits astrazeneca à
prix coûtant donc il y a eu
certainement une ombre à cette grave au
tabac ou au départ des gouver nement a
fait de son mieux pour
rattraper la situation un peu
après et a quand même quelques exploits
à son actif
a fait valoir effectivement c'était
l'une de mes prochaines questions le
rapport pointe a effectivement le succès
de cette politique de vaccination qui
selon lui l'une des plus efficaces au
monde en tout cas effectivement vous
avez défendu ce bilan de ben johnson en
tant que vice-président du parti
conservateur britannique en france merci
paul thompson d'avoir été avec nous
en allemagne les personnes non vaccinées
contre le commis 19 doivent désormais
payer une dizaine d'euros pour se faire
dépister les tests gratuits reste
toutefois en vigueur pour les personnes
non vaccinées pour des raisons médicales
et femmes enceintes et les enfants de
moins de 12 ans avis partagé dans les
rues de berlin
d'un côté c'est vrai si vous ne vous
faites pas vacciner vous devez payer
d'un autre côté la réalité est que les
gens ne vont pas du tout se faire
dépister je ne sais pas ce qui est juste
cela des avantages et des inconvénients
beaucoup de gens ont eu le temps de se
faire vacciner oui mais cela signifie
que vous ne pouvez plus contrôler les
chiffres exactement comme la contagion
tourner
dans un sens oui et dans un autre nom
[Rires]
[Musique]
pour les personnes qui ne se font pas
vacciner même si elle le pourrai je
dirais que c'est leur propre faute mais
pour ceux qui ne peuvent pas par exemple
pour des raisons de santé c'est un peu
dommage mais sinon je suis vacciné cela
ne me regarde pas
personnellement je n'aime pas le fait
que les stations de test gratuit et
était supprimé il s'agit simplement
d'une pratique commerciale si je veux
aller à l'hôpital alors que je suis
vacciné je dois montrer un test pour
quoi
en revanche les tests sont toujours
gratuits pour sensibiliser la population
objectif tenter d'inverser les chiffres
épidémique en constante augmentation en
toile de fond le débat sur la
vaccination obligatoire antico vide les
correspondances à mon secours d'antoine
frérot
depuis ce lundi 11 octobre la ville de
moscou a ouvert une vingtaine de centres
de test où la population peut donc se
faire tester gratuitement et ce en
quelques minutes comme par exemple ici
dans le célèbre centre commercial goom
en plein coeur de la capitale afin
d'enrayer la situation sanitaire duo
kobe 19 certains en russie évoque la
possibilité de mettre en place un
système d'amande afin de sanctionner les
non vaccinés mais le kremlin a fait
savoir qu'une telle mesure était
irréaliste et qu'il valait mieux user de
pédagogie afin d'inciter la population à
se faire vacciner
je pense que je fais partie de ceux qui
considèrent cela comme une nécessité
le fait est que beaucoup de mes
camarades de classe et beaucoup de
membres de ma famille travaille comme
médecin dans les zones de qu'ovide
il ya des voies y étudier et j'ai vu ces
gens et je crois qu'il est temps de les
sauver c'est tellement dur pour eux
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre solution
il est nécessaire de se faire vacciner
c'est obligatoire si on parle de covile
19 je pense que la vaccination est
nécessaire
bien que l'effet du vaccin ne soit pas
entièrement connus chaque semaine nous
apprenons quelque chose de nouveau et ce
n'est pas toujours bon ni agréable
mais la vaccination est importante et
nécessaire cela peut être comparé à la
variole que l'humanité a vaincu
voulait vite nous nous faisons tous à
l'idée que la vaccination est
obligatoire plus il y aura de gens qui
se font vacciner plus vite on mettra fin
à cette situation compliquée
quoi qu'il en soit les chiffres restent
mauvais en russie sur ces six derniers
jours on dénombre plus de 900 décès
quotidiens avec la mise en place de ce
test gratuit et rapide les autorités
cherchent donc à limiter la propagation
du virus sans nuire à l'économie
sur le fond de la campagne vaccinale aux
états unis de texas les bandes à part
une fois de plus le gouverneur
républicain interdit l'obligation
vaccinale des entités de son état y
compris aux entreprises privées n'ont
pas tout de suite avec notre
correspondante aux abonnés à washington
bonsoir thomas c'est une décision qui va
à contre-courant des des choix du
président bédaine une façon certainement
pour le texas une fois encore de mener
sa fronde anti démocrate
oui parce qu'en réalité cela fait des
semaines que ce gouverneur républicain
du texas s'oppose à la maison blanche
sur un grand nombre de sujets et
particulièrement sur cette crise
sanitaire cette fois donc le gouverneur
républicain du texas greg abbott a
décidé d'interdire la mise en place des
obligations de vaccination pour toutes
les entités à texane et dans le décret
qui a été signé ce lundi on comprend que
c'est une réaction directe aux mesures
présidentielles prises par joe biden
écouter
considérons que dans une nouvelle et
exagérations des instances fédérales
l'administration byden malmène
maintenant beaucoup d'entités privées
pour imposer des obligations de
vaccination causant des interruptions de
travail qui menace le rétablissement du
texas suite au désastre du coc vite 19
aucune entité au texas ne peut
contraindre à la présentation d'une
preuve de vaccination contre le coc vite
19 incluant les employés et les clients
qui s'opposent à une telle vaccination
pour quelconque raison de conscience
personnelle basée sur une croyance
religieuse ou pour des raisons médicales
comme une ancienne guérison ducobu 19
alors pour compléter ses propos et
montrer qu'il n'était pas anti vaccin
agrégat bot a tweeté le vaccin covic 19
est sûre efficace et constitue notre
meilleure défense contre le virus mais
il doit toujours rester volontaire et
jamais forcé alors les contrevenants
dans l'état du texas risqueront une
amende allant jusqu'à 1000 $ et ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que l'état du texas
comme l'état de floride d'ailleurs sont
donc deux états qui sont gouvernés par
des républicains et cela fait maintenant
plusieurs mois qu'ils se sont constitués
en figure de résistance en quelque sorte
aux mesures prises à l'est shell fédéral
d'ailleurs il ya eu une réaction il y à
quelques instants à peine de la part de
la porte parole de la maison blanche
james acquis qui dit regretter que ces
deux gouverneurs place la politique au
dessus de la santé publique et thomas
c'est dans ce contexte qu'une compagnie
aérienne a connu des perturbations ces
derniers jours peut-on y voir un lien
avec la mise en place de la vaccination
obligatoire pour les employés justement
et bien c'est tout le débat stéphane il
faut d'abord savoir que ce dimanche plus
de mille vols ont été annulés par cette
compagnie aérienne southwest airlines
alors dans un premier temps l'entreprise
s'est justifié en prétextant des
problèmes de météo ainsi que des
problèmes de contrôle aérien mais pour
certains notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux on a pu lire des tweets par
exemple du sénateur républicain a
peut-être cruz est bien pour eux elle
ces problèmes étaient une conséquence
directe de la mise en place de
l'obligation de vaccination pour les
employés de cette entreprise ce qui
aurait donc entraîner des absences mais
c'est une thèse qui a été réfutée
d'abord par un syndicat de pilotes de
l'air puis par le patron de l'entreprise
southwest airlines lui même qui a donné
une interview en expliquant qu'il
s'agissait en réalité de problèmes
d'effectifs et des problèmes de planning
mais son interview n'a pas suffi à
éteindre toutes ces rumeurs qui
circulent sur les réseaux sociaux parce
que dans la même interview le patron de
southwest explique aussi qu'il est
farouchement opposé à l'obligation de
vaccination mais qu'il est contraint de
s'y plier pour respecter les mesures
prises par joe biden qui je vous le
rappelle a imposé la vaccination à plus
de 100 millions de salariés sur
l'ensemble du territoire d'ici le 8
décembre prochain il y à un fait qui est
intéressant c'est que cette compagnie
aérienne southwest airlines a son siège
dans l'état du texas ce qui veut dire
qu'elle pourrait ne plus se contraindre
à c'est à ces directions directives
prises au niveau fédéral et justement se
soumettre à ces nouvelles mesures prises
par le gouverneur républicain mais
finalement on a appris que cette
entreprise allait bel et bien se plier à
ses obligations de vaccination mais il
ya beaucoup d'entreprises qui sont en
réalité dans le même cas de figure qui
ont leur siège basé au texas et on
devrait donc avoir des batailles
juridiques que dans les semaines à venir
avec évidemment en font une opposition
entre les républicains de ces états et
l'administration démocrate et puis une
dernière information pour finir
stéphanie je sais que vous aimez bien le
basket et bien sachez qu'un joueur de
l'équipe de brooklyn vient d'être écarté
par son équipe parce que lui aussi
refusent de se faire vacciner alors dans
leur championnat de basket aux états
unis il n'y a pas d'obligation de
vaccination mais le fait qu'il évolue
dans une équipe qui est basée à new york
et bien cela l'empêchent de pouvoir
jouer les matches à domicile de son
équipe raison pour laquelle il a été
écarté et preuve que l'obligation de
vaccination mis en place aux états unis
a des répercussions sur tout un tas de
secteurs effectivement merci thomas
bonnin en direct de washington et pour
approfondir ce sujet nous sommes avec
douglas soya aux spécialistes en
sciences politiques américaines bonsoir
nous assaillent et merci d'être avec
nous cette interdiction de l'obligation
vaccinale au texas est une façon comme
nous l'expliqué à l'instant thomas
bonnet d'attaqué politiquement joe biden
selon vous
oui au fond de la vaccination c'est une
question de santé publique
mais en réalité ça s'est transformé de
plus en plus dans un marqueur politique
et donc un mac pro tisane républicaine
au marqueur des heat rouge et ils jouent
avec les vies des gens même si je suis
contre l'obligation de se vacciner il me
semble comme on dit dans des démontre
aussi avec des libertés et si un choix
personnel mais un mais ces politiques
qui exige certains personnels comme dans
les grandes sociétés aériennes nous
donne des hôpitaux se vacciner me semble
raisonnable et pour opposer à ces
politiques simplement pour les raisons
politiques c'est c est responsable c'est
un conditionnables les états unis sont
sont connus pour être avoir souvent une
politique très très libérale ans basé
sur la liberté
individuel on l'a vu d'ailleurs dans la
gestion de la pandémie la joe biden qui
veut rendre la vaccination obligatoire
pour 100 millions de travailleurs à ce
que ce n'est pas étonnant
oui donc en édition d'être une question
de santé publique est maintenant
question politique on a aussi les
questions légales et heureusement et
malheureusement c'est une système
fédéral et je vois ce tout ça comme
comme quoi que de fédéralisme donne la
cacophonie
fédéraliste dans certaines cités il est
l'égal de fumée marouane dans les autres
c'est illégal d'une seule chine c'est
clair un autre de prostitution deux
autres têtes prostitution est illégale
et maintenant avec les vaccinations avec
le kobe en grande variabilité entre les
états et ça c'est la cacophonie de faire
de l'islam ça c'est une question légale
tu parles n'a pas les moyens de forcer
le gouverneur des textes appliqués sont
politique fédérale mais avec les avions
il est possible parce que le transport
aérienne et sous le régime réglementaire
des gouvernements fédéral mais dans les
autres dom et non un le gouveneur
détectrices à la liberté de deux opposés
à ces politiques des vaccinations obligé
on l'a vu à l'aller les républicains
veulent mener des poursuites judiciaires
au nom des libertés individuelles
comment réagit selon sont les des
américains parce que je le répète ils
sont plutôt attachés d'une manière
générale alors liberté ces américains
comment réagissent ils face à cette
envie de vaccination obligatoire de joe
biden
ceux qui s'opposent il y a beaucoup
d'éloignement qui sont violées tout le
temps bloc contre les drogues les gens
utilisent les drogues est donc à il y a
une résistance au niveau individuel donc
ces politiques collectives il y en coûte
de désobéir le noir mais finalement les
jeunes sont bien capables
les dissidences civile d'une telle
question de vaccination
une question au delà de ce sujet de
vaccination obligatoire le texas en l'a
vu ces derniers temps devient quasiment
l'illustration d'une fronde à anti joe
biden antidémocrates on entendait
d'ailleurs certains invités venus du
texas dont dire il ya une vraie rupture
d'une certaine amérique avec ce
président qui semble loin de leurs
préoccupations
le président des élites de washington
des grandes villes démocrate est ce
qu'il ya un petit peu de de cela qu'elle
se joue aussi
oui vous donne la présidente
présidence du donnant 30 on a vu les
gouverneurs démocrates des états comme
californie au new york s'opposer aux
politiques nationales et maintenant
c'est le tour des républiques al de
faire le même démarche donc ce qui est
bien pour le chat c'est bien pour un
chien et à et diane ce job hayden
rassemble quelques institutionnels
inside the band il a passé toute sa vie
à washington et le procès psion qu'il
sort des élites n'est pas fausse
mais a au contraire le parti des
meilleures habitudes et gouverneur de
floride eux le vrai goût venir opposé
cette pratique anglo propre mal en plus
est et c'est vrai événement le plein
d'amis rage aux états unis on a sept
cent mille morts aux etats-unis à cause
de ce pas d'amis il faut finalement
trouvé une solution pour se rassembler
les deux parties dans une politique
commune est
justement l avènement de
l'élection de joe biden à trump d'avoir
fracturé l'amérique la diviser en deux
camps
finalement la lumière de tous ces
développements est ce qu'on se dit
aujourd'hui joe biden fait-il mieux en
ce sens non il essaye de ressembler les
deux coatis mes mains est devenue une
société pro reese et politiquement du
moins le bol nous verser deux mois ils
sont tus ashton de politique ils ne sont
pas à pratiquer comme clément disant tu
lui as et dans le parti mais censé
devenir une société
polarisée et urban elle n'a pas la
capacité de faire les lois bipartisane
ordures budget et déjà des choses de
base qu'il a promis et même avec son
expérience de travail avec mitch
mcconnell et pratique républicaine au
congrès n'est pas un jour et travaille
avec les gouverneurs dont un système
faudra prendre ne semble impossible
donc les divisions sans pierre de plus
en plus et peut-être qu'ils font mais
n'en est rien pour unifier les
américaines mais sans cela 1 1 6 6 7 6
aux pays en voie de développement
on pourrait dire ça c'est une dommages
de guerre civile ça ne se produise pas
mais les prochaines élections ce sera
décisive de voir si les modérés sont et
loue aussi plutôt les légendes extrême
gauche extrême droite qui occupe toutes
les places dans nos sympathiques
porter votre
et dans le reste de l'actualité
internationale cette rencontre
aujourd'hui à doha entre les talibans
d'un côté une délégation conjointe etats
unis union européenne de l'autre et
disent que sur moment où les dirigeants
du g20 s'engagent à travailler ensemble
pour éviter une catastrophe humanitaire
en afghanistan
ils promettent un soutien à la
population mais sous certaines
conditions
les explications de sébastien rabat la
communauté internationale s'active pour
l'afghanistan une crise humanitaire et
socio économiques menacent le pays
depuis la prise du pouvoir des talibans
le 15 août dernier pour éviter le pire
la commission européenne s'est engagée à
accorder une aide d'un milliard d'euros
nous devons faire tout ce qui est en
notre pouvoir pour éviter un
effondrement humanitaires et sociaux
économiques majeurs en afghanistan le
peuple afghan ne doit pas payer le prix
des actions des talibans c'est pourquoi
l'aide est destinée au peuple afghan et
aux voisins du pays qui ont été les
premiers à leur apporter de l'aide c'est
aide humanitaire sera acheminé grâce à
des organisations internationales sur le
terrain d'autres sources de soutien
étranger sont proposés au pays dans une
démarche plus globale pour l'aider à
relancer son activité économique dans le
cas du g20 le gouvernement taliban devra
pour cela respecter certaines conditions
fixées par les états membres de ce
groupe parmi elles l'autorisation
continue des départs du pays pour
raisons humanitaires
la condamnation par les talibans des
groupes terroristes sévissant dans la
région mais aussi le respect des droits
de l'homme et en particulier la dignité
des femmes lourdement pénalisés par la
politique du pouvoir en place ce mardi
une rencontre entre une délégation des
talibans et des représentants d'état
influents a eu lieu à doha au qatar le
médiateur qatari a rappelé l'importance
de communiquer avec les nouveaux maîtres
de kaboul
je pense que collaborer avec eux est la
chose la plus importante actuellement et
si nous revenons en arrière et ne
collaborons pas avec eux je pense que
nous commettrons à nouveau l'erreur de
1989 quand nous nous sommes laver les
mains de l'afghanistan quand nous avons
abandonné le pays et le peuple afghan
est l'une des conséquences de ce choix
ce fut le 11 septembre nous devrions
donc en tirer les leçons
les discussions en cours ont pour
objectif d'établir des liens
diplomatiques avec l'afghanistan est
d'amener à terme la reconnaissance du
gouvernement taliban la direction le
liban présents pour parler de ce nouveau
rebondissement dans la quête sur
l'explosion du port de beyrouth de jeu
chargé d'instruction à nouveau été
contrainte de suspendre ses
investigations en cause le dépôt d'une
plainte contre lui par deux députés
qu'il souhaite auditionner le secrétaire
général du hezbollah l'accusé également
de politiser l'investigation et demande
son remplacement françois xavier lambert
c'est un contretemps de plus pour la
justice libanaise
le juge chargé d'enquêter sur la double
explosion du port de beyrouth devait
auditionner ce mardi le député et
ex-ministre ali hassan khalil mais ce
dernier ne s'est pas présenté devant le
magistrat visé par un mandat d'arrêt il
a de nouveau déposé un recours devant la
cour de cassation qui entraîne la
suspension de l'instruction depuis sa
nomination tarek bitar et dénigré par de
nombreux acteurs de la classe politique
libanaise qui dénonce une enquête
politisé hier soir le secrétaire général
du hezbollah l'a de nouveau mis en cause
cela ne veut pas dire que nous appelons
à la fin de l' enquête pas du tout mais
nous appelons à la nomination d'un juge
honnête pour travailler en toute
transparence sur cette enquête avec
toute la clarté nécessaire
des responsables politiques de tous
bords refuse d'être interrogé par le
juge hormis ali hassan khalil d'autres
anciens ministres sont mises en cause
comme ghazi zeaiter qui a lui aussi
déposé un recours devant la cour de
cassation
pointé du doigt pour négligence
criminelle les autorités ont refusé
toute enquête internationale et sont
accusés par les familles des victimes d'
empêcher la justice de travailler des
familles qui ne peuvent oublier la
double déflagration du port de beyrouth
qui a dévasté des quartiers entiers de
la capitale libanaise il ya plus d'un an
elle aurait été causé par le stockage
sans mesure de précaution d'énormes
quantités de nitrate d'ammonium
plus de 200 personnes ont péri dans la
tragédie
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
à nous parlerons du plan france de mai
30 annoncés par emmanuel écran ce matin
un plan destiné à défendre la
souveraineté économique du pays à
l'international
30 milliards d'euros pour maintenir
paris dans la course à l'innovation
mondiale l'opposition dénonce une
démarche électoraliste à la proche de la
présidentielle
[Musique]
ne
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux et de
aidé de jean ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter ils étaient ni sur la liste
des morts ni sur les db c'est une
surprise et hopitalisé il était nulle
part est ce qu'on peut vivre malgré
cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à la fois
je souffrais parce que ça me rappelait
des beaux souvenirs avec stéphane en
même temps c'était très douloureux et
puis aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que
ça permettait d'extraire de de moi même
toute cette histoire est donc ça m'a
apporté un peu de recul un peu
d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
on
certains font entendre leur voix pour
les autres et le silence qui parle
[Musique]
la communication des modèles mâcon aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
victhom est ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant poule et où ça n'a plus
rien depuis c'est pour se rapprocher des
jeunes mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup
trop déconnecté de la sphère politique
il pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à
la politique d'entre eux
désintéresserait en lieu et place de
politiser les jeunes ça dépolitise la
politique en la rendant encore plus nesc
justement c'est une nouvelle forme de
communication assez verticale utiliser
des influenceurs pour moissac hommes
politiques personnelles est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est vraiment nouveau
d'utiliser des célébrités pour faire de
la propagande politique on s'en fiche
nous on veut quelqu'un qui dirige la
france comme c'est son travail en notre
nom pour nous est dans notre intérêt à
tous
[Musique]
le coeur des femmes est plus fragile que
celui des hommes en france c'est 200
femmes par jour qui décèdent de maladies
cardio cérébrovasculaires c'est à dire
ses choeurs cerveau artères et c'est une
véritable urgence épidémiologique parce
que c'est l'hygiène de vie qui a fait
celui des maladies cardiovasculaires des
femmes première cause de mortalité six
fois plus que le cancer du sein par
exemple il ya toujours trois fois plus
importante chez les hommes que chez les
femmes mais ce qui nous alertent nous
c'est la progression du nombre de femmes
jeunes hospitalisés pour infarctus vous
expliquez que ça n'arrive pas par hasard
c'est une maladie qui est évitable dans
huit cas sur dix est évitable ça veut
dire que l'hygiène de vie c'est notre
facteur de risque numéro un on a plutôt
un système de soins qui est unique et
accès fléché sur le traitement de la
maladie soupçon diagnostic et le
traitement et non pas sur la prévention
et on est dans un système très curatif 1
c'est essentiel d'avoir l'information
pour pas subir
[Musique]
en afghanistan le passage du pouvoir aux
talibans après vingt ans de guerre est
une défaite pour l'ensemble des
occidentaux en tant que membre de l'otan
un pays comme la france peut se poser
des questions sur la vision américaine
de l'organisation et la prise de
contrôle du marché des sous marins
australiens par les états unis montrent
qu'une alliance entre anglo saxons pour
faire face à la chine est en train de se
construire c'est un signe manifeste
d'une longue dégringolade de notre
posture à la fois stratégiques
politiques sur la scène internationale
et industriels aussi les pays européens
sont ils perçus comme des pourvoyeurs de
troupes de supplétifs au service des
états unis ou bien des alliés et de
véritables partenaires
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi qui ait des candidats
n'y a pas d'alternative en sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft
est ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
l'uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose dignité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer qu une
sixième république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct il y a
quand même la liberté je vous remercie
de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire que doit-on retenir du plan
france annoncée par emmanuel macron un
plan destiné à défendre la souveraineté
économique de la france à
l'international hydrogène vers voiture
électrique réacteurs nucléaires innovant
de petite taille agriculture tourné vers
la robotique et la génétique des
secteurs prioritaires sur le chef de
l'état qui débloquera 30 milliards
d'euros sur cinq ans l'opposition
dénonce une démarche électoraliste à la
proche de la présidentielle décryptage
dans quelques instants
[Musique]
30 milliards d'euros donc pour maintenir
paris dans la course à l'innovation
mondiale une enveloppe annoncée
aujourd'hui par emmanuel macron pour
lancer son plan france 2030 un
dispositif centré notamment sur
l'industrie de demain yamina benguigui
da pour les détails
30 milliards d'euros d'investissements
pour remettre la france sur pied telle
est l'ambition d' emmanuel macron à
l'horizon 2030 l'accent est spécialement
mis sur l'énergie la réindustrialisation
et l'innovation
son but permettre à la france de se
faire une place de leader qu'elle aurait
perdu ces dernières années notamment
dans le secteur de l'automobile le
président souhaite ainsi investir 4
milliards d'euros dans ce qu'il appelle
les acteurs des transports du futur
c'est pour ça que le quatrième objectif
pour moi est de pouvoir produire en
france à l'horizon 2030 près de deux
millions de véhicules électriques et
hybrides
nous ne voulons pas nous grande nation
de l'automobile devenir la nation qui
roulera le plus vert avec des voitures
qui ne sont plus produites chez nous ça
n'a aucun sens de faire ça
soyons le site sur nous mêmes les trente
dernières années ont été cruels pour
l'industrie automobile française
c'est le fruit d'erreurs de politique
industrielle c'est le fruit de stratégie
non coopératifs entre les acteurs de
l'industrie eux mêmes ils ont une énorme
responsabilité dans cette situation et
c'est le fruit d'une d'un choix qui a
été longtemps le choix français d'une
sous compétitivité industrielle une
touche de vert dans la production
d'énergie
emmanuel macron se lance un défi celui
de faire de la france le leader de
l'hydrogène vers l'idée étant de
profiter d'une source d'énergie qui
n'aimait pas de carbone deuxième
objectif
devenir le leader de l'hydrogène vert en
2030 là je le dis en l'assumant
totalement quand ça fait partie vraiment
d'un des secteurs où nous pouvons être
leader c'est une vraiment une filière
dans l'énergie nous pouvons encore le
faire parce que nous avons des atouts
une énergie verte oui mais un recours au
nucléaire clairement pérenniser dans ce
secteur emmanuel macron souhaite
injecter 1 milliards d'euros qui servira
à améliorer l'équipe manque de
production le locataire de l'elysée veut
par exemple remplacer les réacteurs
nucléaires actuelles par de petits
réacteurs de nouvelle génération
permettant une meilleure gestion des
déchets une proposition qui fait bondir
les écologistes ces derniers y voit un
déni de l'urgence climatique
macron annonce un milliard pour le
nucléaire dont les smr dont on ne
maîtrise pas la technologie mais 500
millions seulement dans les
renouvelables ou la france accuse
pourtant un retard conséquent lohan chez
greenpeace critique de son côté un
festival de fausses solutions et de
voeux pieux après un plan de relance
prétendument verts et des chèques en
blanc aux industries polluantes présenté
pendant la crise du coc vide de
nouvelles enveloppes sont dédiés à des
industries polluantes sans contreparties
sociales et écologiques solide avec son
nouveau plan d'investissement
le président ne fait pas l'unanimité
l'opposition de droite comme de gauche
dénonce une forme de propagande destinée
à redorer son blason électorale à huit
mois de l'échéance présidentielle
emmanuel macron lui n'a toujours pas dit
s'il va être candidat à sa réélection
un plan france de mes 30 ans dénoncées
par certains une partie de l'opposition
parle d'un chèque en blanc avaient faim
électorale à six mois de la
présidentielle écouter
nouvelle journée de propagande macro
nist sur un plan d'investissement la
vérité les sommes étaient déjà prévus
nouveauté des centrales nucléaires
partout qui décide macron tout seul
nucléaire hydrogène start up quand
emmanuel macron sort le chéquier annonce
un plan d'investissement de 30 milliards
d'euros à six mois des élections
cela s'appelle faire campagne avec
l'argent des français est en bien de
l'entente les voix s'élèvent donc à
droite comme à gauche face à ce plan du
président une proposition qui parle d'
annonce à des fins clairement
électorales approchent de la
présidentielle et ce alors qu emmanuel
macron n'est pas encore candidat déclaré
dans le même temps vous aviez bertron
rentrer dans le rang aujourd'hui il a
finalement accepté de participer au
congrès républicain c'est l'heure de
notre décryptage politique
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler avec six
poulains dit orianne liste rt france
bonsoir alexis et vos côtés eric revel
éditorialiste politique vous venez eric
revel de publier fenêtre de tir la
présidentielle 2022 et le grand retour
de l'ordre aux éditions au ring merci
d'être avec nous ce soir avec nous pour
nous accompagner également l'éclairage
de l'entrepreneur et observateurs
politiques que vous êtes également denis
jacquet bonsoir
réindustraliser pays pour devenir une
grande nation d'innovation ce sont les
mots donc des manuels mettront ce matin
qui a détaillé avec précision à ses
ambitions industrielles pour un deuxième
quinquennat même s'il le dit pas encore
un plan de 30 milliards d'euros
d'investissement regardés et mène les
mâcon qui dit donc vouloir produire deux
millions de véhicules électriques et
hybrides en france notamment d'ici 2030
c'est ambitieux de se positionner pour
2030 alors qu'on n'est même pas encore
en 2022 alexis pour l'un c'est un peu
ridicule et alors j'ai envie de dire à
quoi sert françois bayrou il est
commissaire au plan c'est lui qui est
censé faire un peu ces planifications
alors on apprend dans un livre aussi qu
apparemment banale macro aurait payé
bayrou impôts qui le soutiennent là il
fait ce qu'il aurait dû faire lorsqu'il
est arrivé au pouvoir le problème du
modèle macron c'est que pendant des
années tout sa formation son logiciel
politique idéologique s'il en est un
c'est d'être dans la fusion dans
l'intégration européenne dans la
mondialisation et de vendre les bijoux
de famille d'avoir des industries et la
france de faire de la france un pays de
services est aujourd'hui découvre à
cause ou grâce à la crise du coc vide
que on est totalement mises à nues quand
une crise arrive et qu'on ne produit
plus sur le sol national on perd des
emplois et que c'est impossible alors il
a beau jeu aujourd'hui de dire qu'il va
redire du site réalisé deux pays alors
qu'il a passé sa carrière finalement à
des industriels pointent le plan attali
par exemple
c'est quand même le président de la
start up née sean qui étaient là pour de
porter sur un nuage hubert et ne dire
que des lointains sur l'ubs et risation
l'économie et là il se rend compte que
non une économie sans industrie ça ne
fonctionne pas alors tant mieux qu'ils
ne s'en rendent compte maintenant le
seul problème c'est que on voit bien que
c'est dans un timing de deux campagnes
politiques et combien va nous coûter
aujourd'hui la campagne des manuels
macron voilà ça se chiffre en milliards
mais tout ça c'est des promesses et
c'est uniquement pour son image
d'ailleurs ils se réservent voyez il est
sur scène comme sur un teddy x c'est
vraiment le télévangéliste qui est là
pour dire je suis génial je vous promet
des milliards eric revel ya une prise de
conscience soudaine des manuels macron
c'est vrai que même avant d'être
président le ministre de l'économie
avait démantelé certains fleurons de des
entreprises françaises prise de
conscience sincérité ou fins
électoralistes comme vrai quand même ça
c'est un fait qu'on peut vérifier c'est
qu'il ya jamais eu autant de fusions
acquisitions et 2
bradage de certaines entreprises
françaises que lorsque emmanuel macron
et ministre des finances ça c'est un
point certains ce que j'aurai dire quand
même et je regardais vos titres tout à
l'heure c'est que start up start up
nation again je veux dire c'est le
problème à mon avis des manuels macron
c'est qu'à mon sens quand on est
présentement république et c'est l'un
des sujets de mon livre on doit incarner
la fonction on ne doit pas considérer le
pays comme une start up on doit
considérer le pays comme une nation avec
tout ce qu'on doit protéger à
l'intérieur d'une nation doit rassembler
on doit pas diviser on doit mettre du
baume sur les crises et non pas donner
l'impression qu'on est con aviv les
plaies alors moi j'ai l'impression
aujourd'hui que emmanuel macron poursuit
dans cette dans cette voie là c'est à
dire il y gère un peu la france comme il
gérait une grande entreprise ce qu'il
finira peut-être par faire s'il est
battu en 2022 et et je pense que c'est
pas le rôle du président république
alors maintenant à l'excision la raison
quand vous êtes en pré campagne il faut
dire si vous faites le calcul depuis
quinze jours trois semaines de tout ce
qui a été promis aux différentes
corporations
en france vous allez voir que la
calculette ministre camélia voilà on
sait même pas d'ailleurs exactement
comment on va payer tout ça on aidait de
2002 ni écouté avec intérêt ce je vais
justement denis jacquet vous
l'entrepreneur qui avaient beaucoup
avaient causé aux états unis quand même
y avait une nécessité
on va pas rentrer dans le détail
effectivement de deux disques ont enfin
bon les semi conducteurs qu'on
produisait part en france il ya quand
même cette prise de conscience à la
faveur justement de la pandémie c'est
salutaire ou vous êtes aussi sévère
causé dollar sur le plateau
ouais ils y ont appris à connaître
alexis j'étais pas surpris mais je suis
ravi de retrouver notre autre ami aussi
on s'est pas parlé depuis très longtemps
donc et moi je suis toujours aux états
unis maintenant j'y vis définitivement
écoutez le
c'est quand même dommage d'attendre
quatre ans et presque et demi avant de
s'apercevoir qu'il était bon d'avoir de
l'ambition pour la france on se demande
pourquoi on en a pas eu depuis le début
d'autant qu'on sait qu'une année pèse
une éternité aujourd'hui en matière
technologique 6 heures quand vous perdez
huit mois vous avez perdu huit ans donc
il ya quand même eu une vie avant le
vide demain donc du coup c'est vrai que
pour tous ceux qui avaient suivi un peu
macron dont je faisais partie à
l'origine on avait tous pensé qu'une des
premières dispositions les ambitions de
la france serait justement d'en avoir
une mais on a été très déçu parce que un
an deux ans rien bon une année et demie
de queue vide c'est clair mais donc un
la première chose je pense que c'est on
pourrait dire c'est mieux vaut tard que
jamais mais néanmoins aujourd'hui elle
s'en apercevoir juste avant les
élections c'est quand même un petit peu
c'est quand même un petit peu borderline
mais c'est le jeu des politiques
habituels à la projection la deuxième
chose c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de 1
comment dire d'euros maquillage de
mesures déjà existantes donc c'est pas
30 vrai nouveau milliards
c'est des trucs rafistolé du plan de
relance qu'on nous a promis qu est
jamais venue du plan de
réindustrialisation
on nous a promis par le vide à peu près
tous les jours et dont on attend
toujours le début d'un d'un exercice et
puis surtout je voudrais lui rappeler
enfin dans mon précédent bouquin sur la
chine pourquoi votre prochain patron
sera chinois et d'ailleurs il va encore
être la plus rapidement avec des
ambitions aussi petit c'est que assez
étrangement
la dixième ville chinoise en 2019 avait
investi sur l'intelligence artificielle
seulement juste là dessus
10 milliards d'euros vous imaginez une
seule ville la dixième de chine 10
milliards d'euros donc 30 milliards
c'est beaucoup c'est l'argent des
français on sait pas d'où il sort
puisqu'on en a pu donc en fait encore de
l'argent qu'on va vraisemblablement
inventé mais surtout si on veut une
ambition si une ambition européenne
d'abord et pas uniquement française
parce que le jeu aujourd'hui et les
acteurs sont mondiaux ils sont pas
français donc il faut aller se battre
contre la chine et des états unis et
c'est pas avec 30 milliards qu'on va
aller les chercher et c'est sur cinq ans
ces 6 milliards par an mais qu'est ce
que vous faites avec similaire sais même
pas ce qu'a dépensé sur un seul sujet
une seule ville chinoise en une année
donc je pense que là c'est assez
ridicule dans le montant alors du coup
c'est pas le contre-pied exactement de
ce que disait à dexia jean françois c
c'est juste qu'en réalité cet argent-là
parle il est re maquiller et si tenté
que ce soit une bonne idée il est
totalement je dire l'échelle aujourd'hui
d'investissement on le sait pour être
dans les secteurs d'avenir c'est une
centaine de milliards et donc ça vous le
trouvez pas en france et c'est pas sur
cinq ans c'est pendant tous les ans
pendant cinq ans et au niveau de
l'europe le spatial dans lequel on prend
un retard considérable donc je pense que
les le dernier point que j'ajouterai on
l'a vu avec le plan de relance et alexis
genre en soi qui observe çà depuis a
longtemps c'est qui va recevoir cet
argent ou va-t-il être allé par qui va
être administré et distribué parce que
je peux vous dire qu'ils n'aiment pas
cheap d'entreprise la question de la
gouvernance on en parlera en étant airs
et eric revel alors bruno lemaire défend
évidemment sur le migou 30 et vous dis
ce soir la mise de l'économique ça va
créer 45 milliards de de richesses et
des dizaines de milliers d'emplois
c'est forcément un peu l'emploi mais je
pense que on est plus à l'échelle oui
d'une certaine manière la comparaison
que vient de faire des ninjas qu'elle
est très importante parce que et vous
montre dans lequel état et la france
aujourd'hui et son économie s'apercevoir
qu'on a des industrialisés au nom de la
mondialisation heureuse pendant des
années des années ce pays et s'en
apercevoir six mois avant l'élection
présidentielle s'est déjà à mon sens
une faute des manuels m non mais
attendez attendez ça doit pas des menus
et mâcon mais ce que je veux dire par là
c'est qu'on n'est plus du tout à
l'échelle la comparaison que faisait
denis à l'instant elle est très
significative on parle du déclin de la
france vous le mesurer également sur ces
chiffres les revers quand on vient de
subir c'est une façon pour le présent
appuyé de reprendre la main on vous
annonce des chiffres ronflants on n'a
pas les comparaisons montrent l on pense
tout bas c'est les deux regardez ce qui
s'est passé en australie avec les sous
marins regarder comment la france est
traitée à l'extérieur sur la sphère de
la réduction des visas pour les pays du
maghreb on a vraiment l'impression
pardonnez moi l'expression
et c'est par appeler un mauvais épisode
emmanuel macron mais qu'on se prend des
claques tous les jours si vous voulez on
se prend des claques tous les jours
c'est à dire que c'est l'argent qui est
mis sur la table à des fins
électoralistes n'est pas à l'échelle de
ce qui se passe dans le monde et
notamment du développement de
l'intelligence artificielle ou parler
denis et est ce que c'est un combat
perdu d'avancé alexis
à forces égales dans cette affaire mais
on joue pas du tout à forces égales on
est dans un âge d empire américain
chinois russes aussi qu' un plan depuis
des années nous l'europe on est
incapable de s'organiser c'est
extrêmement compliqué on est toujours
dans une compétition larvée avec même si
on est en train de dire qu'on va
travailler ensemble on voit bien que les
pays européens sont dans la compétition
et n'ont pas les mêmes intérêts c'est là
tout le problème aussi la construction
européenne avec en plus les agissements
qui a rendu encore plus compliqué des
projets d'envergure donc on est
incapable de faire des projets
industriels regardez sur arianespace ça
coûte plus cher maintenant que ce p 6
alors que on avait des années d'avant ce
donc on doit se poser la question à la
fois de ses moteurs la de la recherche
pourquoi on ne peut mener incapable en
france de payer nos chercheurs pourquoi
on les forme très bien et pourquoi ils
s'en vont tout de suite on les paye pas
donc il ya des filières alors c'est ce
qui s'est dit aujourd'hui par un
résidant dans celles qui est quand même
un français nommé pdg
de moderna qui est parti aux états unis
et qui dit on n'a pas été capable en
france de garder nos deux ingénieurs et
et non chercheurs il est là le problème
on pourrait s'y attend bien sûr bien sûr
eric revel sur les sur la sphère de
leblanc scène moderna c'est un sujet
très intéressant ce qu'ils ont voulu
interroger il vous dit quoi il vous dit
qu'en france en fait il aurait eu le
capital humain pour
développer et modern a mais il n'aurait
eu ni le soutien financier public ni le
soutien financier privé c'est ça qui est
incroyable parce que toutes ces
aventures puisqu'on parle beaucoup de
vaccins et principes actifs à cause de
la crise sanitaire sont des aventures
industrielles qui sont nés la plupart du
temps avec des start up justement donc
le président de la république eh oui
mais justement justement c'est là c'est
là où on a un problème c'est que on vous
fait des grand-messes comme celle ci
pour vous expliquer qu'on va déverser
des milliards d'euros et on avait des
startups en france à nantes qui à cake
qui a servi à développer un vaccin qui
était utilisé en grande bretagne on a
des start up qu'on ne connaît pas qu'on
regarde à peine et en même temps on a un
outil qu'ils délocalisent en permanence
souvenez-vous toutes ces grandes marques
industrielles qu'on a paumé pechiney qui
se souvient de pechiney aujourd'hui mais
quand pechiney été rachetée pechiney
c'était l'un des fleurons industriels
français ça a été racheté la marque a
disparu c'est la même chose en l'aidant
dans dans d'autres secteurs où on a
perdu des fêtes la liste des entreprises
mondiales françaises qui ont disparu
vous allez voir que c'est absolument
frappant et en fait on ne cesse d
indiciels en france c'est une qui note
un peu comme un patron de start-up
justement or c'est le président de la
république c'est pas à lui de faire ce
discours il est devant des patrons pour
dire on va aider les patrons donc en
france on parle beaucoup macron parle
beaucoup il se met en scène comme un
patron de start up mais c'est pas ça qui
va faire que ça marche donc la réalité
c'est que sur cette scène là devaient se
succéder des patrons qui aurait dit
qu'elle était leur succès on a vu ça
lors du sommet bpi un peu mais mais
clairement il est là dans une mise en
scène encore une fois de pour son
électorat pour dire je voyez on parle
d'emploi on parle de création
d'investissement d'emploi pour les
années à venir mais ce qui intéresse
aujourd'hui les gens c'est quoi c'est
leur perte de pouvoir d'achat quand vous
regardez ce qui se passe sur le prix
d'énergie mais vous voyez vous ayez le
président de la république fait une
intervention pour dire dans x années
vous allez avoir des emplois et 45
milliards d'euros de de valeur ajoutée
dit bruno le maire mais ce qui intéresse
les français au quotidien c'est de
savoir comment ils vont payer aussi
leurs factures l'électricien justement
il a parlé du nucléaire il semble miser
beaucoup sur le nucléaire avec notamment
voilà le nucléaire de petite taille
denis jacquet vue de vue des états unis
ça vous semble séduisant on va s'en
sortir grâce à ce genre de d'initiative
du président
non mais je pense que là et eric l'a
bien rappelé alexis aussi c'est le
problème des chaînes c'est pourquoi la
france ne peut pas être à l'échelle de
la chine des états unis l'europe le
pourrait donc mais regardez la
difficulté avec laquelle pour un christ
decaux vide ils ont accouché d'une
mesure de relance de combien 600 700
milliards il a fallu des mois des
semaines de négociations ce qui revenait
à quelques dizaines de milliards par
pays et cet argent c'est toujours
d'ailleurs pour la plupart pas où il est
donc du coup comme on n'a pas un
alignement ne peut pas avoir d' europe
on ne peut pas être à l'échelle donc
tout ça pour moi c'est pour ça que
j'essaye de rester sereins dans le débat
et de ne pas être trop dogmatique mais
très honnêtement le timing de
l'opération le niveau qu'il est en train
d'afficher et les mesures qui à
l'intérieur quand on sait qu'après ça
passe par des ministères des régions une
administration technocratique et que cet
argent en fait on le verra véritablement
jamais pour bruno lo mèr promettre de la
valeur ajoutée des emplois franchement
c'est on est en ça frise la malhonnêteté
donc peut-être que oui enfin moi je suis
né en normandie peut-être ben qu'oui
ptêt ben qu'non mais j'aurais quand même
tendance à dire plus tôt peut-être ben
qu'non mais en tout cas pas à ce niveau
là donc et aujourd'hui on a beaucoup
plus de sujets qu'on devrait traiter qui
vont vous savez la valeur c'est simple
ça va de la recherche fondamentale au
fait de denfert des entreprises et qui
deviennent mondiale maintenant que vous
avez pas une recherche fondamentale qui
est bien payé donc vous avez pas
décloisonner la recherche et le business
tant que vous donnez pas des moyens non
pas c'est pas une start up née shon dont
on a besoin on a besoin de leaders
mondiaux c'est pas des start up de cinq
personnes avec 2 millions d'euros dont
on a besoin cette boîte qui font des
centaines voire des milliards de chiffre
d'affaires et qui partent à la conquête
du monde où on n'a pas cet état d'esprit
on n'a pas cette vision que l'éclairage
tout de même qu'ils sont les les
florentins va pas si mal en france
néanmoins on vit sur nos acquis de lvmh
s'est pas d'aujourd'hui mais je veux
dire je cherchais où est le moteur de
recherche le plus utilisé au monde où et
les réseaux sociaux les plus utilisés au
monde enfin regarder toutes les grands
services digitaux les plus utilisés au
monde malheureusement une son nid au
robin sont absolument pas euros et
notamment pas français donc on a su
faire on pourrait savoir parce qu'on la
france est un magnifique pays avec des
gens fantastiques
malheureusement ils n'ont pas les
dirigeants qu'il mérite alors on va
aborder une autre question politique un
opposition évidemment qui dénonce des
fins électoralistes justement on y est
presque 1 dans six mois on va jeter un
petit coup d'oeil au cdj ifop du jour
d'hier plutôt sur les intentions de vote
des français regardez l élection
présidentielle en avril prochain xavier
bertrand est au coude à coude avec
marine le pen talonné de très près par
eric zemmour qui ne s'est toujours pas
déclaré on le rappelle clairement lexsi
à deux candidats en dynamique et
l'eczéma ou exavier bertrand
emmanuel macron louis les plus tôt
confort pour l'instant encore et
toujours emmanuel macron comme eric
zemmour n'est pas déclaré candidat il va
se déclarer le plus tard possible
puisque là il fait campagne sans faire
campagne c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
facile pour ce qui est de xavier
bertrand ça se complique puisqu'il a
accepté de participer au congrès des
républicains sans reprendre sa carte du
parti sachant que là il va se soumettre
au vote qu'il va pas être le seul et à
valérie pécresse qui aimeraient aussi y
aller et puis il ya le grand absent de
ce débat legrand silencieux on va dire
laurent wauquiez et qui pèse encore un
au sein du parti pour qui va-t-il aller
leur en ce moment on parle d'un wauquiez
qui ils iraient derrière barnier et ça
pourrait totalement changer la donne de
ce congrès donc aujourd'hui on fait des
sondages sur de l'air puisque le congrès
n'a pas eu lieu puisque des candidats ne
sont pas encore déclarés enfin c'est une
présidentielle c'est un marathon il ne
fait que commencer et on voit bien que
sur la ligne de départ est vrai qu'ils
prennent de l'avancé mais ça veut pas
dire qu'ils vont aller au finish et
souvent d'ailleurs les sondages
d'octobre d'un vol le gagnant et les
crevel pari risqué la pouvoir xavier
bertrand cantat lors plusieurs choses
quand même quand vous regardez un peu
les sondages des campagnes
présidentielles précédentes au moins
deux observations la première c'est que
un président sortant qui est à 24 25
dans les sondages c'est extrêmement bas
en réalité c'est extrêmement bas parce
que dès l'instant qu'un président en
fonction se déclare en général il perd
3,4 points donc si vous enlevez cette
marche là vous êtes dans un étiage de 10
19 points potentiels pour emmanuel
macron ça veut dire que s'il ya pléthore
de candidats notamment à gauche c'est à
dire que la barre du second tour
peut-être et à 16 17 18 points donc tout
le monde donne évidemment emmanuel
macron au second tour pour l'instant il
faudra voir ce qui va se passer je nie
pas qu'il n'y sera pas je dis que 24 ou
25 % d'intentions de vote pour un
présent un public sortant avant qu'il se
déclare de nouveaux candidats c'est pas
un score si élevé que ça deuxième chose
sûre xavier bertrand bon les sondages
montrent que ce serait le seul à pouvoir
peut-être battre emmanuel macron je
remarque une chose c'est que il ya
quelques semaines xavier bertrand a
expliqué qu'il n'y aurait qu'un candidat
chez les républicains ça veut donc dire
que il savait que d'une façon ou d'une
autre il devrait passer sous les
fourches caudines d'une primaire qui l'a
refusé que son parti a ouverte a
finalement refusé ou d'un congrès moi ce
que je pense mais c'est vrai que
l'attelage wauquiez michel barnier peut
monter en puissance que je pense quand
même c'est que dès l'instant où il va y
avoir ce congrès la pire des choses pour
les républicains me semble-t-il c'est
que ce soit une sorte de foire d'emploi
n'y que le résultat ne soit pas clair et
net vous savez où vous souvenez
peut-être lors de l'élection d'un
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
mon cher alexis poulain ça mettait aux
prises deux dames madame martine aubry
et madame ségolène royal je me souviens
en début de soirée madame ségolène royal
avait quelques milliers d'oies davance
et au petit matin quand on s'est
réveillé madame martine aubry a lui
gagné avec 190 voix d'avancé et elle est
devenue premier donc sous les ja je ne
dis pas tout ça n'est pas transparent je
dis simplement que la pire des choses
pour un congrès des républicains s'ils
veulent mettre en orbite un candidat
c'est qu'ils soient élus de manière
claire nette et précise et que les
autres candidats peut-être potentiel
négocié avec celui ou celle qui peut
gagner des places dans un futur attelage
si c'est pour avoir une cacophonie
totale
vaut mieux personne ne se présente pour
les républicains et que le congrès du 4
décembre
ils passent directement aux 24 pour
fêter noël denis jacquet en fin
observateur de la politique française
également depuis les etats unis eric
revel le disait un candidat à droite et
le plus vite possible comme le souhaite
sa vie et bertrand parce qu'on a vu
toute cette voie la ccc petit
rebondissement avec ce phénomène
médiatique ou pas on en débattra une
autre fois mais mes eric zemmour qui est
quand même venu mettre un petit peu un
coup de pied dans cette fourmilière et
et changer un peu la donne
moi je trouve ça très intéressant
d'avoir un outsider puisque je suis
entrepreneur j'aime l'indépendance la
liberté de parole d'esprit et d'action
et donc le fait d'avoir je dis pas eric
zemmour mais un candidat comme eric
zemmour je pense ne peut faire que du
bien la campagne parce que sur des
sujets clés il va être les autres vont
être obligés de se positionner et
d'avancer enfin des choses concrètes sur
des sujets qui de toute façon préoccupe
véritablement et pas seulement les
français vous dire que c'est un sujet
dans tellement de pays du monde
aujourd'hui le restreint à francs sera
un peu limité je pense que les
républicains ont un problème c'est qu'en
fait ils ont malheureusement pas cette
fois là un candidat à la hauteur de la
tâche dire que moi je trouve que
bertrand est très bien dans la région
nord pécresse s'est fait plutôt du bon
boulot c'est des candidats qui sont des
très bons régionaux comme il ya des
régionaux de l'étape dans le tour de
france mais ils ont pas le disons c'est
pas un sarko c'est pas voilà il me
manque un truc quoi donc barnier on est
tellement enfin julien si on commence à
donner les clés de la france à quelqu'un
qui a eu les clefs de l'europe dont on
connaît le succès ça me fait plutôt peur
qu'autre chose même si le personnage en
lui-même pas désirable en fait ils n'ont
pas un candidat à la hauteur c'est ça
qui leur manquent et puis la dernière
chose ce qui manquerait à cette campagne
c'est une femme mais je veux dire une
vraie face par exemple une christine
lagarde ou quelqu'un comme ça à
quelqu'un qui est vraiment
internationale qui a une vision du monde
qui sait ce qui s'y passe capal nombre y
concentrer sur la france mais qui sait
que les enjeux sont internationaux
aujourd'hui sont globaux et qui serait
le gérer avec une vraie bienveillance
donc je pense que cette campagne donc
beaucoup de féminisation comme toutes
les campagnes d'avant et malheureusement
peut-être encore celle d'après merci en
tout cas donné jacquet
crevel merci beaucoup de votre présence
adexi poulin et c'est la fin de cette
émission rendez vous demain dès 20
heures pour un nouveau numéro numéro
d'ici là n'oubliez pas de réagir de
commenter de poser vos questions sur le
télégramme berthet france excellente fin
de soirée à tous
[Musique]
la communication des modèles mapon aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
pickton est-ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant poule il est où ça n'a
plus rien fait pour se rapprocher des
jeunes mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup
trop déconnecté de la sphère politique
il pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à
la politique dont il se désintéresserait
en lieu et place de politiser les jeunes
ça dépolitise la politique en la rendant
encore plus clownesque justement c'est
une nouvelle forme de communication
assez verticale utiliser des
influenceurs pour un sac hommes
politiques personnelles est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est vraiment nouveau
d'utiliser des célébrités pour faire de
la propagande politique on s'en fiche
nous on veut quelqu'un qui dirige la
france comme c'est son travail en notre
nom pour nous aider dans notre intérêt à
tous
le volontarisme politique atteint ses
limites dans les français sont de plus
en plus sceptique
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
l'uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï paix gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct il y a
quand même la liberté je vous remercie
de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
bienvenue dans afrique connect nous
sommes à montpellier ville hôte le 8
octobre du nouveau sommet afrique france
et aussi d'un contre sommet dont
l'objectif est de dénoncer les maux de
la françafrique une la continuité de la
politique française sur le continent
africain dans divers domaines que ce
soit économique monétaire avec la
réforme du franc cfa par exemple
regarder
comment ça va
loin des caméras des médias et des beaux
discours on ne peut pas avoir une france
qui construit son propre roman national
comme on dit si elle n'assume pas sa
part d'africanité se dérouler un autre
sommet le 8 octobre dernier à
montpellier organisée par une dizaine
d'associations le contre-sommet été
rythmée par plusieurs conférences
rassemblements et manifestations dans le
but de pointer du doigt la continuité de
la françafrique de sa politique
migratoire à l'ingérence dans
l'assassinât de thomas sankara si le
procès de ces assassins présumés s'est
ouvert hier à ouagadougou le mystère
persiste autour de l'ancien président du
burkina faso arrivé au pouvoir après un
coup d'état alors qu'il n'a que 33 ans
celui qu'on appelle